all right welcome everybody to the Chess
Club
plastic center we just
sixty-eight Louis other than potential
and we have possibly the winner possible
tied for first I'll find out in a few
minutes when free market finishes his
game we have America's GM and sometime
in this very loud chess club you managed
to get you know it's it required the
tournament so welcome to the club now
what you're saying is it took you 18
months to two years to them all you're
normally doing just the last six left so
you've had all of your worms except the
16 one for a long yeah and so you're
just waiting to get this storm sink now
you've got the newer did you beat it on
but you've not that you be the
grandmasters I might know him he looks a
lot like maybe he doesn't play as well
let his handsome either okay so if you
had to describe your best game of the
tournament Oakley wasn't with me what do
you think it was you could say me if you
want I will be yeah I remember this game
you've finally broken
yeah I was looking good and what was
your worst kid you ever be in wreath on
you play really badly or just falling
throughout my first game was definitely
the worst against Ashley I got nothing
the opening is why he surprised me I
just thought Marvel oversight at one
point he could have played a simple move
52 in that game that sticky missile it
was like it's funny your worst game was
around one of your best game of round
two then the rest of the game rest
assured with smooth sailing yeah
so you had four wins and five draws yeah
and your life two draws were sort of
perfectly and your arms and the title
and all that when do you expect fee day
we'll put the stamp on Geo next to your
name yeah so hopefully soon yeah and
then we'll go to feed a and your little
sage EMI shondrea
and what's your feet are waiting right
now after this tournament 2500 very good
and what's your plans for the future
just what we'll say Lewis is here and
you're gonna play a lot more chest you
have any big points lined up no this
starts here in a couple of days yeah
okay well that's our newest a
grandmaster America how old are you 77
are you sure you know understand I'm so
he's my wife okay 70 year of ox shot
Shankara the America's newest GM a long
time in the making he had all the nura's
we needed this is one norm over 2500 for
a long time welcome to the club